you know some sometimes it's like gee
like if somebody complains that
something's bad in Wikipedia whoever
they are don't care who they are it
could be
you could be the government could be the
Pope I don't care who they are it's like
oh okay well our responsibilities
Wikipedia is to go oh hold on let's
check right is that right or wrong is
there something that we've got wrong in
Wikipedia not because you're threatening
to block us but because we want
Wikipedia to be correct so we do have
these dialogues with people and
um you know a big part of
like what was going on with
you might call it pressure on social
media companies or dialogue with
depending on you know as we talked
earlier grapple with the language
depending on what your view is
um in our case it was really just about
oh okay right they want to have a
dialogue about a covid information
misinformation we're this enormous
source of information which the world
depends on
we're gonna have that conversation right
we're happy to say here's you know if
they say how do you know uh that
Wikipedia is not going to be pushing
some crazy anti-vaxx narrative
um first I mean I think it's somewhat
inappropriate for a government to be
asking pointed questions in a way that
implies
possible penalties I'm not sure that
ever happened because we would just go I
don't know the Chinese blocked us and
so so it goes right we're not going to
cave in to any kind of government
pressure but
um whatever the appropriateness of what
they were doing I think there is a role
for government in just saying let's
understand the information ecosystem
let's think about the problem of
misinformation disinformation in society
particularly around election security
um all these kinds of things so you know
I think it would be irresponsible of us
to get a call from a government agency
and say yeah why don't you just [__] off
you're the government uh but it would
also be irresponsible to go oh dear
government age it's not happy let's fix
Wikipedia so the FBI loves us so when
you say you want to have discussions
with the Chinese government or with
organizations like CDC and who it's to
thoroughly understand what the
mainstream narrative is so that it can
be properly represented but not drive
what the articles are well I yeah it's
actually important to say like whatever
the Wikimedia Foundation thinks has no
impact on what's in Wikipedia so it's
more about saying to them right we
understand you're the World Health
Organization or you're whoever and part
of your job is to sort of public
health is about Communications you want
to understand the world so it's more
about oh well let's explain how
Wikipedia works so it's more about
explaining how Wikipedia works and like
hey it's the volunteers yeah yeah it's a
it's a battle of ideas and here's how
yes the sources are used yeah what are
the legitimate sources and what not a
legitimate sources yeah exactly I mean I
suppose there's some battle about what
is a legitimate Source there could be
statements made that CDC I mean like
there's uh government organizations
in general have sold themselves to be
the place where you go for expertise and
some of that has been uh to small degree
raised in question over the response to
the pandemic I think in many cases and
this goes back to my topic of trust
so there were definitely cases of public
officials public organizations
where I felt like they lost the trust of
the public because they didn't trust the
public yeah and so the idea is like we
really need people to take this
seriously and take actions therefore
we're going to put out some overblown
claims because it's going to scare
people into behaving correctly you know
what that might work for a little while
but it doesn't work in the long run
because suddenly people go from a
default stance of like the Center for
Disease Control very well respected
scientific organization sort of I don't
know they've got uh fault in Atlanta
with the last vial of smallpox or
whatever it is that people think about
them and to go oh right these are
scientists we should actually take
seriously and listen to and they're not
politicized
um and they're you know it's like okay
and if you put out statements I don't
know if the CDC did but the Health
Organization whoever that are provably
false and also provably you kind of knew
they were false but you did it to scare
people because you wanted them to do the
right thing
it's like no you know what that's not
going to work in the long run like
you're going to lose people and now
you've got a bigger problem which is a
lack of trust in science a lack of trust
in authorities who are you know by and
large they're like quite boring
government bureaucrat scientists who
just are trying to help the world